hi guys I'm Maddie I'm a second-year
biologist at some Peters and I'm this
year's JCR access rat hello I'm one I'm
a third-year history student I've just
finished my final exams and I was the
access web before Maddie last year hey
I'm Amy I am a first date historian and
I'm going to be the access rep next year
you guys submitted some questions about
life Oxford and the application process
and so we're all here to answer them for
you today argent spirit sent a question
what is Oxford's position on research on
modules and years no I don't know about
three thirteen years I know there are a
few people I know MUFON who have had
like gap ears and stuff so I'm not sure
I don't think it's much different to
that um but I know I reset quite a few
of my history more well both of my
history modules for AAS and they were
absolutely fine with it like I was
applying with my great like my
application talks what happened and I
hadn't reached at them yet I was still
on the grades that I wasn't happy with
um when I was applying and I still got
my office so I think that it's not a
problem
Omni um yeah taking years out thing the
only thing I would say that is that ie I
did an aw early and basically I wasn't
sure whether it came to do my exams in
my final year at school whether they
would count the year before because
Oxford's main sort of Lionel messes that
you should try and get the free a levels
a free grades you need in the same year
cuz otherwise people couldn't just do
one a year and accumulated gradually no
one actually does but icicle probably
but that's the kind of idea behind the
album behind the principle but I mean I
saw situations if you're unsure about
anything like that do get in contact
with the academic with in admissions
administrative of the college or Oxford
because they can be very helpful things
like
and quite flexible as well so we had a
lot of questions about pooling and the
polling system of Oxford we should start
by clarifying that Cambridge also has
its own important system which is
actually quite different to what what
we're talking about here
Pauling at Oxford means applying to one
college and going into another or
getting moved around during entry
process as that's what we're going to
talk about here if you're interested in
the Cambridge cooling system which is
quite distinct quite better to go and
talk to someone gave vigil go on their
website Pauling of Oxford when you apply
talk to them if you get an interview
even if you've not applied to a specific
college you'll be assigned the college
as part of the admission process and
it's very common in during interviews to
be moved throughout the different
colleges and then you might get a place
at college you didn't apply to the
reason being is that Oxford's the
university is looking for the most
academically able students who apply to
it not the people who just happen to
apply to a particular college end up
taking it yeah
so as you could see how that would sort
of people would try to cheat the
statistics and that sort of thing which
happens every year you get with spikes
in graphs or their emissions and people
who've applied but don't do that because
it makes absolutely no difference and
has no impact on your chance of gaining
they are anything for the ways
academically able people so yeah it's
quite a new view out so yeah so we you
to put Paul but also the other thing I
need if you do get called don't worry
about it doesn't mean like you could not
fathom what they're doing I know people
who have had like pools to five
different colleges I myself applied to
Peters was pulled to Somerville and then
got my place at Peters
so it doesn't really make any sense so
don't worry or stress when you if if you
like get Paul today or anything uses are
and the amount of interviews you have
however many colleges you have the
interview that it kind of depends on
your subject so I do biology and I had
two interviews and you have one at the
college I applied and
my second college and so I applied to
Martin and my second interview was at
Peters and I had those two interviews it
was pretty straightforward and then
going Peters some people had those two
interviews and then they got pulled to
another college
some people were called back for more
interviews other colleges so like Amy
said you don't know what really what
they're going to do you can't always be
sure how many interviews you'll have
they're just trying to make sure that
they are thorough there's a good thing
about for this they will they'll give
you food and accommodation for the whole
of your interview period so I know I'm
like I have to stay an extra night
because when I got pulled
I miss my train home and they were fine
with it so like they were really good
about yeah
and that's in terms of about you two
staying in Oxford in general obviously
the interview process by its very nature
is going to be quite stressful but the
thing to remember is you being powerful
and wonderful in an incredibly nice city
for a couple of days and apart from you
interview you get to meet loads of new
people and you get the rest of time to
yourself so do try to enjoy it and this
whole idea of moving to different
colleges and stuff yeah the main thing
is it's totally unpalatable so don't try
to worry about it is it true that if you
don't have relatives who went to Oxford
you have a lesser chance to get a richer
more anyway yeah no it's not true
sometimes sometimes you hear these weird
stories about families who've been to
Oxford for three generations and they
went to the same College and it seems a
bit suspicious but technically no if you
are smart enough and if you work hard it
won't matter what your family did for
whatever subject you're applying for go
on that google that subject and Oxford
and there'll be a subject page for that
and they'll give you a really long
pedantic list of criteria about your
academic ability which is file of our
less exciting than relatives and we went
to things like that
blast what's actually truly important so
don't look at that
you